welcome to this video playing a 500 game
guess chess mark from from Belgium this
guy is very low rated from the
five-minute pool I mean I rarely get
players below 2000 to 1600 okay so we
have a banker gambit yet tried trying to
vary my openings let's see what he's
coming up with his playing the main line
nowadays I guess that's the main line
would be one now son the muth why you're
sixteen hundred i know this line okay
let's check this alright some send out
wit account it's not turn not the new
account interesting okay so i was going
for Knight b6 because I recently saw
this idea will be three mmm mmm I was
displayed actually
yeah i'm not an expert on the Bangko of
this lip may be here to see seven I
don't know okay I know I played it and I
played an entirely do it entirely wrong
move order what I was I can show you
afterwards now it's what I was confused
and then and too screwed up the move
order I mean nothing totally terrible
happened but I am here they're here the
snide ft 7 or Bishop g7 and then that ft
said this is what whatever what I was
referring to what I saw recently yeah
yeah how to get get counter play here
neither be five is going to take and
play a form and that's not not great
yeah maybe prepare it I mean I cannot
take really on c3 and ani too because of
bishop age six but huh here maybe so
this does not look to tlie great for
black rly and i still can after night b5
can player to capture a day form
yeah but what else am I going to do
alrighty Scotty five also taking 85 mm
it's not great not at all if I take with
the Queen may be taking with the Queen
and then Queen eat you up something
trying to disturb him the task a drug to
all the time okay
mm yeah what is just substantially
better here yeah that's one of the
reasons now he is even threatening 'if
I've you know taking is not the worst
part ii five is the the re6 is the the
the big problem yeah probably i must
move the Queen here may be here I don't
know I mean just just very bad now e6 I
can play at five I just totally
weakening the Kings side but not sure
what else to do okay daddy six is also
weakness son this is not bad at all okay
yeah i can i can go here intending
Bishop f5 bishop b6 Bishop f5 windsor
woods material yeah I think maybe I've
gained a bit of coordination here in the
d5 pawn is a bit weak and unless unless
I'm overlooking anything substantial and
when Bishop f5 coming do you five we
gather this is this is somewhat better
than before yeah i think it i think ii
six was more more dangerous than than
capturing okay get this in yeah probably
i should
okay so who the should you fall or maybe
just retreat the night to attack the
pawn have the same night is also
pressurizing d5 at the moment but
getting some role for my rook sir cannot
be bad so attacking be 30 light can go
to e7 any way to attack d5 again I also
had a bishop affords also what's
interesting ok maybe rook rook somewhere
up here to have rupee 700 g 7 you can
take a look take c5 here maybe details
we should be eight hmm maybe this was
possible ok didn't happen
yeah couldn't play Bishop f6 Wow Queen
you ain't now
yeah back to be six huh wow what a game
yeah it's not not great really
not much choice problem i get this
exchanged at least d5 is hanging or
Queenie eight Queenie a half 97 at the
end okay Queenie a drogue a droopy at
Bishop f8 bishop age six but i have
ninety-seven at the end okay whoo that
was close very typical mating pattern
Alan Turing okay now i can take on d5 or
not there then no i have covered h6 so i
can take it
all my pieces are covered d 5 and the
rooks
looks very shaky ok ok at least I got
got this traded eyes got this one hmm
hmm that's that's the time that's
unfortunate I can't make half this have
this mucho still keep my pawn him ok
take it it's not greater rook e8 mate
yeah night comes to f5 wow I'm not quite
sure what this guy is doing with 1600
and he keeps finding a really good move
check
an ID f5 now is a big threat trapping
the the beside four hits I'm telling ya
know I've got I've got the bishop now
but wow what a game ever was totally
totally busted right out of the opening
I mean it can happen if you play a
somewhat borderline opening yeah water
lines may be the wrong word but the
bangko is is somewhat risky am if you
don't really know what you're doing you
can be in trouble on quickly what what I
was basically forgetting is that this is
the move order that I wanted to play
this way always looking at PR not from
g6 looking at the night so that b3 is
not easily playable and I forgot about
that and then I got into I guess
probably one of the worst versions of
this opening line well I'm just worse as
simple as that maybe I am i can improve
somehow but it just does not look right
a computer actually wants to take him
which I dismissed because of this move
but maybe this is some this is maybe a
playable so it's quite ugly but it made
me play ever okay so this is how it went
down and here yeah I'm just I'm just
totally worse here I was I was fearing
he 6m to trying to get an attack on the
King side at the end something like
let's say I play and I never played at
five probably and then let's say h4 h5
it's just a super dangerous attack with
this pawn see I'm totally cutting off
the queenside from the King side and why
just has those attacking pieces looks
very dangerous and well I can take
but here yeah maybe this this I mean
this is just very dangerous was 95 at
the age con coming I mean this would
have been my choice I mean white keeps
an edgy as well but yeah right here I
thought the worst was over but yeah he
could have taken on see fighting I
pointed this out during the video and it
was possible due to the pin yeah yeah
but I'm gross anyway I mean he just
played a really good game yeah so here
maybe it's about equal or something I
did amazing I really kept the position
together really nicely and hear ya ass I
mean clearly worse I'm just just
stumbled into this this bad position
again yeah amazing but at the time would
cause we both had very little time on
the clock so you cannot judge those
moves too harshly right thanks for
watching